it's gonna be a five minute reaction to
ugly dolls five minutes of me singing
Kelly Clarkson and that's why we're all
subscribed okay I'm not saying that
these dolls are ugly by taking my
thumbnail with them I just think they're
hilarious
and I love them so much hi everyone my
name's Tamara chambers and this is Tamra
just saw and tonight I wouldn't saw ugly
dolls what an interesting step from
Avengers endgame am i right I wanted to
this excited to see Kelly Clarkson boy
something because I feel like she can do
no wrong I love her so much
I think she's such a powerful voice such
a dynamic interesting voice and it's
cool that she was the lead voice in this
there's also some incredible other
people in this lizzo Janelle Monae Oh
what but the story was okay this is the
story of moxie an ugly doll who with a
group of other ugly dolls go to find the
big outside world and find a home and
hopefully an owner there adorably ugly
it's great it's really cute the opening
song was awesome it's all very much
about embracing your flaws or not even
looking at them as flaws at all and it's
really cute and I think it's a very nice
thing for kids to see this was aimed at
extremely young kids so sure I wasn't
the market for it but I would argue that
I was because I love Kelly Clarkson did
you Megan I also don't like the argument
that movies shouldn't be good enough for
like adults to see even over there for
kids like it just it felt it was pretty
bland so they leave ugly Ville to go
find the great outdoors in the big big
world and they fall into like perfect
utopia it's called perfect Ville or
something I don't know very very black
and white Oh ugly Ville and perfect
Ville and then that's where all of the
beautiful dolls come out Nick Jonas can
do no wrong literally
kasa this movie Kelly Clarkson could do
anything to me and I'd be fine with it
saying with Janelle Monae same with Liz
Oh same with Nick Jonas well type one
diabetic nugget Hebron they have to go
through this thing called the gauntlet
which reminded me of Fallout 4 very much
and it wasn't anything like that to my
great disappointment it's just like a
test to show that they're ready to
become adopted by a kid and that's
really all it is one of the main perfect
girls has to wear glasses and so she's
not perfect in the eyes of Nick Jonas
his character and it's just it's it's
it's very cute very aims towards a
younger audience and it is really bland
at the end there's a really sweet moment
where she does finally get adopted and
the person she ends up with has a really
beautiful moment in connection with her
moxie our lead Kelly Clarkson voice doll
and it's really sweet and I felt myself
getting like welled up and emotional
about it but it just didn't feel like
they could have built up towards that so
much better the comedy was super super
flat and the the script was just a
stinker man it was I know am I being too
too mean on I personally was glad that
it was an hour and a half and not longer
I think it could have done well to have
better animation the lips didn't match
up to what they were saying they'd be
like wow I have to say that I love you
very much and you are the best
was that a money thing what's going on I
also watched the trailer for this in
other films that I had seen earlier this
year and thought that's awesome there's
different the first song they're talking
about how she looks beautiful and she's
crooked and fuzzy and look at my weight
and so they just all this was really
cute I I was excited about it and then
came and it was just a little little
lackluster not to say that it was bad it
just could have been a lot better the
voice cast they got the singing was
amazing and I even enjoyed people that I
don't necessarily like love like Eminem
oh I'm not stone not Watson the other
ones also Blake Sheldon that his name I
don't know ah vacant voices it was
really good I think the script and the
animation really really just didn't them
no favors kind of weird that there's a
movie based off these dolls that do
exist I think they just saw these dolls
or like oh we could do this we'll get
some like big names on board it'll do
really well well I it was I was the only
person my theatre tonight and it's the
opening night all right I guess
technically tomorrow is but I mean the
first shows were tonight so doesn't say
amazing things for the movie though
again end game is in its second week so
probably this was me to do with it I
don't know it was cute I don't think
that if it's something you're not
interested in I don't think I'm gonna
change your opinion to go see it with
this glowing review but if it's
something that you really wanted to go
see specially if you have younger kids
or just kids in general or you need like
a fun little sangee boost then hell yeah
go see it but it's not something you
need to see in the big theater in the
big it's not something you need to see
on the big screen I think of anything a
smaller screen would do it justice
because it's kind of like that movie you
put on when you're babysitting and then
you all kind of get into it by the end
and it's fun but the animation is a
great and the script could have done
with a few rewrites and like somebody
coming in and doing like joke joke
writing for them the jokes were awful
look at this hyper fangirl this is my
prized possession I love her
look at this she's like a little potato
oh I love her look at this look at that
the sock monkey hyper fan girl are we
joking I love oh no big deal
she's just hyper fangirl made out of
pipe cleaners look at her I love her if
I got anything out of this movie it was
just that I on the bus ride home
watched a bunch of videos of Kelly
Clarkson singing things she's such a
good voice I love her dearly oh what's
what what's this it's a microphone well
don't mind if I do
I got this at the dollar store for the
first time because of you I never stray
too far from the sidewalk because of you
I learned to play on the safe side so I
don't get hurt because I try my hardest
just to forget everything I don't know
the words
says God she has a high voice time faces
behind these handlebars fall swallow me
and spitting me up for hating you I
blame myself singing you kill me now cuz
I don't the dark side I was gonna do
this reaction video with no makeup on
but I already had makeup on I just
didn't touch it up so I'm looking crusty
and I have many people fail fail he's
bad peace he restores my faith that a
cat can be kind and in I could try not
to reach out when I try to speak out
feel that no one could hear me
why don't you belong here but something
feels wrong here so I prayed I could
break away
the Tarot plays my voice learn how to
fly I'll do what it takes to I could
touches the sky I'm gonna make a wish
take a chance make a change and
breakaway to sad I won't forget the
place I come from I wanna take a wish
make a chance make a wish take a chance
something change and breakaway thank you
so much for watching I will see you all
next week with John wick Chapter three
bye
[Music]